do you think there's uh
a meaning to this thing we got going on
uh life existence
on earth to us individuals from uh
psychedelics researcher perspective or
from just a human perspective
those those merged together for me like
because it's it's just hard i've been
doing this research for
almost 17 years and and like not just
the cancer study but so many times
people like
i remember a session in this in one of
our studies
someone who wasn't getting any treatment
for anything but one of our healthy
normal studies where he was
contemplating the the suicide of his son
um and just these i mean just like the
most intense
human experiences that you can have in
the most vulnerable
situations sometimes like people
like you know and it's just like you
have that have a
and you just feel lucky to be part of
that process that people trust you to
let their guards down like that um
like i don't know the meaning i think
the meaning of life is
is is to find meaning and i think i
actually i think i just described it a
minute ago it's like that transcendence
of everything
like the it's the beauty despite the the
absolute ugliness it's the it's the
and as a species and i think more about
this
like i think about this a lot it's the
fact that
we are i mean we're we come from filth i
mean
we're we're you know we're animals we
come from
like we're all descendant from murderers
and rapists
like we despite that background we
are capable of this the self-sacrifice
and the connection and and and
figuring things out you know true
science and other forms of truth you
know
seeking and and an artwork just the
beauty of
of of music and and other forms of art
it's like
the fact that that's possible is the
meaning
of of life i mean and ultimately that
feels to be creating
more and richer experiences
the from a russian perspective uh both
the dark
the you mentioned the cancer diagnosis
or losing
a child to suicide or
all those dark things is is still
rich experiences and also the
beautiful creations the art the music
the science
that's also rich experience so somehow
we're figuring out
from just like psychedelics expand our
mind to the possibility of experiences
somehow we're able to
figure out different ways as a society
to expand
the realm of experiences and from that
would gain meaning somehow
right and that's part of like this we're
going across different levels here but
like the idea that
so-called bad trips or challenging
experiences are so common in psychedelic
experiences it's like
that's a part of that like yeah it's
tough and most of the important things
in life are really really tough and
scary
and most of the things like like the
death of a loved one like
it told like the greatest learning
experiences the things that make you who
you are
are the horrors and you know it's like
yeah we try to minimize them we try to
avoid them
but and i don't know i think we all need
to get into the mode of like giving
ourselves a break both personally
and society societally i mean i went
through like the the
in the i think a lot of people do these
days in my 20s like
oh the humans are just kind of a disease
on the planet
and like and then in terms of our
country in terms of the united states
it's like oh we have all these horrible
you know sins in our past and it's like
i think about that like the
i think about it like my my
three-year-old it's like yeah you can
construct a story
where this is all just horrible you can
look at that stuff and say this is all
just horror you know where yard is like
there's no logical answer to our
you know rational answer to say we're
not a disease on the planet from one
lens we are
you know you know and like there's
you could just look at humanity as that
like nothing but this horrible thing you
can look at any you and you name the
system
you know you know modern medicine
western medicine
you know the university system and it's
like you could dismiss everything it's a
you know big farm like hopefully these
vaccines work and then like
yeah i'd like to you know like i'm kind
of glad big pharma was a part of that
like
you know it's like the united states you
can like point to the horrors
like any other country that's been
around a long time that has these
legitimate horrors and kind of dismiss
like these beautiful things like yeah we
have this like
modifiable constitutional republic that
just
like i still think is the best thing
going you know um
that that that as a model system of like
how humans
have to figure out how to work together
it's like it's
how there's no better system that i've
come across
yeah there's uh if we're willing to look
for it there's a
there's a beautiful court a lot of
things we've created uh
yeah this country is a great example of
that but most of the human experience
has a beauty to it even the suffering
right so the meaning is fine is is
choosing
to focus on that positivity and not
forget it beautifully but yeah
speaking of experiences this was one of
uh
my favorite experience on this podcast
talking to you today
matthew i hope we get a chance to talk
again i hope to see you on joe rogan
it's a huge honor to talk to you can't
wait to read your papers
uh thanks for talking today likewise i
very much enjoyed it thank you
you